by the way may I may I slouch I'm a
sloucher trying to slouch isn't it isn't
it a little freaky knowing that there
are people just standing there watching
huh I want to pick your brain here Larry
D oh what disgusting expression yeah
well please give her my regards what are
you nuts give her your regard what's
wrong with that first of all no yeah
yeah you're using me okay you don't want
to text her you don't want to reach out
so oh oh Seth Seth gives his regard so I
know this guy he's he's got one eye okay
he takes advantage of the fact that he
only has one eye well he's a he's a
belcher he belches it's disgusting yeah
but because he has the one eye he's
takes advantage of the one eye cuz he
knows nobody is going to correct him hey
I got one eye man you know don't tell
you told our PR let's talk about
anything it's just one thing we don't
want to talk about so let's start there
what do you think about Travis and
Taylor I used the s word once before on
this show some years ago I'm prepared to
use it again